there's this idea that like you know
this is the end of the line America's
doomed uh you know this is we're
reaching levels of authoritarianism that
should be considered impossible and I'm
like guys you have no idea what
authoritarianism is so my mother is
Venezuelan and I had many people
explained to me over the years why
Chavez was wonderful and uh my my
cousins who had to flee from their lives
from his regime were wrong and bigoted
is there not a part of you that when you
hear this you're kind of
feel the need for violence toward these
people
[Laughter]
truly feel my piss boiling whenever they
talk to me my own family they were one
of these so-called gulags and my
grandmother's little brother starved to
death because of what was happening so
there's just so many receipts of of just
uh and not to mention the gulags of
course of atrocities that so many people
whose names we will never know have been
forgotten and I'm like you know Over My
Dead Body is this going to be swept in
the rug of History
um
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant and returning guest
today is a man of many skills and
talents but primarily he's an author and
his latest book is called white pill
Michael malis welcome to trigonometry
thank you so much guys I'm very excited
to be here oh it's great to have you
back on the show man uh you've written
this book uh attempting to get people to
think more positively about their own
lives by highlighting all the horrible
[__] that happened in the 20th century
particularly in the country uh from
which you and I both come what was your
thinking behind doing that
um I I what I was shocked at and I would
love to hear your guys feedback about
this is that the Cold War was the
absolute primary forward policy concern
for both the UK and the US for several
decades and now it's been won so
decisively that people have forgotten it
even happened uh they the Soviet Union
is almost this historical asterisk I
mean there's many movies about World War
II in the States you know we talked with
the Civil War the Revolutionary War but
the fact that this was the complete
utter victory over a disputable evil
empire is just kind of a shrug and it's
just odd to me especially given what the
people of Eastern Europe had to go
through many other countries of course
had to go through for so long that their
story is being swept under the rug
especially when this is something that
occurred within our lifetimes so it's
just very odd to me and
um you know the more research you know
as you said I'm from there the more
research I did the more I realized how
poorly understood the atrocities of the
Soviet Union are maybe perhaps there
isn't a narrative like with World War II
um and I'm like all right well people
need to know more about this and I'm
someone who tells stories so I'm going
to put a stop to that and so I did
um but particularly I mean we can talk
about the Cold War and stuff because
that really is very interesting
particularly given what's going on now
but one of one of the interesting things
to me was the approach you've taken
which is kind of similar to the approach
I took in my book and immigrants love a
letter to the West again trying to
explain to people like things haven't
always been the way they are and things
in most parts of the of the rest of the
world have not been anything like as
comfortable as as what we enjoyed and
what we enjoyed today uh why do you
think that's such an important message
right now well I I think for a personal
level you and I could both speak to that
this is this is what we went through
this is what our families went through
but something that really drives me
crazy and I don't know if this is the
case in British politics here in
American politics especially among
conservatives there's this idea that
like you know this is the end of the
line America's doomed uh you know this
is we're reaching levels of
authoritarianism that should be
considered impossible and I'm like guys
you have no idea what authoritarianism
is and frankly despite having written
you know the book on North Korea as well
I didn't really have a good idea of how
authoritarianism works and how pervasive
it is in Prague there's something called
The Museum of Communism which I set my
protege to visit because they have some
really funny captions uh because it's
not written in a respectful manner it's
you know very derisive about what the
product people experienced and that was
the moment I realized that what we went
through you know our families went
through is the pervasiveness of it all
like if in the states or the UK you hate
Trump or Boris Johnson woke ideology you
can turn it off listen to sports music
read any book you want but there was
nowhere else for them to go in these
countries Everything Everything music
Sports the news the television program
your friends had to be perceived with
the filter of politics and what that
does to a people psychologically is
something I think for all of us uh it's
very hard to wrap our heads around but
it's very important to try to Grapple
what that reality is like
Michael do you think part of the problem
is that we're simply not educated on the
evils of Communism so when people see
communist Heroes that Allah Guevara on a
t-shirt they go oh that's a freedom
fighter when actually if you scratch the
surface the Cuban regime were pretty
brutal to put it mildly
I think and that's by Design I'll put on
my tinfoil hat for this because I think
Western media outlets and this is
something I cover extensively in this
book had so much blood in their hands
and they ran so much interference not
for communism as an ideology which we
can understand okay someone has this
world view they're promoting it that so
on and so forth but for literally Stalin
and the atrocities and you know there's
a great movie called Mr Jones about how
Gareth Jones who'd been a British
reporter uh got out of the train a few
stops earlier and exposed what was going
on in the holiday more with the
starvation of the ukrainians and it
wasn't just that this was being kept
quiet by Western sources is that he was
personally derided as you know a liar
someone who's uh kind of had these
prejudices against the Soviet Union so
decade after decade this wasn't just
World War II where it's like all right
we gotta team up with Stalin to fight
Hitler we could wrap our heads around
that argument but even before that you
know they were making so many excuses
and not just excuses but advocating for
the idea that the Soviet Union is is the
nation of the future and one of the
cover girls on the book is Emma Goldman
you know who is a violent Anarchist who
believed in bloody revolution in her own
words she got deported to the USSR she
fled with her partner in crime Alexander
Berkman and very famously she was in
London uh you know after they left and
you know when she was giving a talk
Standing Ovation right red Emma's here
you know she was the the OG when it
comes to you know red radicalism and she
goes Guys these are this is not a nation
for the workers what they're doing to
these workers is things the Czar would
ever think of and by the time she was
done you could hear a pin drop and they
were telling her who had just left who
had sat down with Lenin personally and
said this isn't what we're supposed to
be for we're supposed to be free speech
for free speech and for the workers they
told her she didn't know what she was
talking about so that kind of idea of
people in the west these intellectuals
influencers from the Comforts of their
own home feeling comfortable explaining
to people who were there that they don't
know what they're talking about how
things really are is a trend that I
think has continued to this day in very
disturbing ways and I completely agree
with you Michael so my mother is
Venezuelan and I had many people explain
to me over the years why Chavez was
wonderful
and uh my my cousins who had to flee
from their lives from his regime were
wrong and bigoted
yeah
I have to ask you do you is there not a
I'm not joking at all is there not a
part of you that when you hear this
you're kind of
feel the need for violence toward these
people
doesn't really feel my piss boiling
whenever they talk to me but it it came
to the point in my own life where I
realized that talking with these people
it wasn't going to lead to anything
because they had their own way of
looking they had their own way of
thinking and when Venezuela inevitably
collapsed and we have 96 of the
population living in poverty they've all
moved on to the next cause and the
reason that socialism didn't flourish is
because it wasn't allowed to flourish
it's the same old narrative yeah but
it's it's not just the narrative which
we could all wrap our heads around it's
that oh you don't know what you're
talking about and I do and it's like
because I read I don't know what
newspaper would be equivalent there but
I read the New York Times I read the
Washington Post therefore I'm an
informed citizen it's just
unconscionable uh and and again they're
case after case of you know uh authors
vice presidents and reporters who went
to these places and feel comfortable
pontificating uh to their lessers about
what things are really like over there
well it wasn't there this uh is it
Durante the New York Times journalist
who got he got a Pulitzer for basically
covering up all the atrocities that were
happening in the Soviet Union
technically he got the Pulitzer earlier
because he also got an interview with
Stalin so that wasn't why he got the
Pulitzer but the headline was Russians
not starving merely hungry or something
of that effective
I I I I get why you laugh but it's like
these are millions of people who are
starved to death intentionally and and
the thing that's really scary he said oh
there's there's no famine nor is there
likely to be and then he says the
Russians are merely tightening their
belts well you know why you tighten your
belt because you don't have food that I
mean it's not a fashion statement
they're not doing the treadmill and the
way the which I didn't even realize how
the whole door more worked you know they
want to requisition all the grain they
wanted to break the culocks so they
would go to your home in the middle of
the night and if you weren't gaunt if
you weren't losing weight they knew you
were hiding food your own body would
betray you it was the law that you had
to starve and and when Gareth Jones the
reporter went to these Villages they
told they all told him the same thing
we're doomed there's no food coming and
it's it's a really kind of
um something that's been swept on the
rug historically and and thankfully I
could discuss a little bit more in this
book yeah right and we we actually did
an interview with a very good historian
of the Soviet Union called Giles UD and
in that I talked about my own family
they were one of these so-called kulaks
and my grandmother's little brother
starved to death because of what was
happening so when we laugh we laugh
because the line is ridiculous but of
course he's a terrible tragedy uh
there's no one would would underplay
that uh I gotta say what I got to be
pedantic it's not a tragedy this was
done but you know this wasn't some for
you know some hurricane or you know like
some typhoon this was an atrocity hmm
yeah it's it's a very good point Michael
but as well you know the the journalists
who went against the grain even very
famous left-leaning journalists like
Malcolm muggeridge I mean it didn't help
their careers did it no he talks yeah
they you know when he when you go
against the kind of uh narrative that
your industry is putting forward
um you know they asked Malcolm Margaret
cheers later because he was a hardcore
Lefty I think his dad was in the fabians
uh so he had the pedigree and they asked
him well what happened to you as a
result of exposing this because he used
a diplomatic Satchel to get the
information out of the Soviet Union he
goes oh me I couldn't get work so the
the fact that their depravity and
malfeasance was exposed by one of their
own uh they knew to seek retribution and
that's certainly the case nowadays when
people in certain industries uh step out
of line their um uh their techniques to
make sure that that doesn't happen twice
and Michael what do you make of of the
situation now where uh in the west quite
often people and look that there's some
evidence that societies have become more
referred to earlier more authoritarian
and people go oh this is just like you
know this is almost like a digital Gulag
and you know this is Soviet how do you
feel about people doing that yeah when
Mike Mike Bloomberg was mayor of New
York City and he had a ban on how big
the sodas you can get at 7-Eleven was
and Mike Huckabee who is governor of
Arkansas at the time his daughter just
became Arkansas governor said this is
like North Korea and I'm like I I assure
you uh the size of the soda is not the
issue in North Korea so I I think these
glib
um hand wavings are are things that I
find uncomfortable
um and again this is one of the reasons
I wrote this is because people think
authoritarianism is just like okay you
have to go to school and they teach you
stupid things and you can't speak out
about politics and everything else is
fine and if that was the extent of of it
I I'm kind of almost fine with that
right we're talking about living from
morning to night in constant fear and at
night you're waiting for the doorbell to
ring when you don't know who's going to
turn who against each other and the
techniques that the Soviet Union used to
make sure people broke which I did you
know discuss extensively in this book
were very clever I mean they they were
very smart about how because people sit
here think okay there's nothing you can
do to me that's going to make me kind of
you know spill or sign a confession I
didn't sign well you have children don't
you so when you have this kind of
collective guilt and when human life and
human rights don't exist you know very
quickly no matter how tough you are
let's get your kid in front of you and
see what you're going to confess to you
you had Jews confessing and plotting
with Hitler you know since before Hitler
was in power it was just absolute
Madness
yeah well this was and again it doesn't
even have to be as Extreme as like we're
gonna kill your child I mean I talk
about this in my book my grandfather uh
said some things about the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan and within a
very short period of time him and his
wife lost their jobs and both their
children were kicked out of University
right so this Collective punishment
system and this is in the 80s so the
period you're talking about earlier it
would have been way worse and of course
you had a system if you were married to
an enemy of the people quote unquote
that was a crime it was a crime to be
related to somebody who's an enemy of
the people it gets much worse than that
because here's what happens you're
you're arrested Constantine right then
your wife is arrested for being in any
of the people what's she gonna do she
can't really plead Innocent but right
away your kids are now orphans overnight
now the thing is what happens to these
kids no uh this happened to Gorbachev
when he was a kid because one of his
grandfathers was arrested and in his
words his house became a plague house
now none of the other kids are going to
play with that kid the teachers are
going to make it a point the distance
self from that kid in fact there's a
story in the in the book where you know
one girl who overnight became an orphan
because her parents were vanished she
had a family friend they took her in but
he went uh someone high up in I believe
his Moscow or St Petersburg and said
what do we do about this kid and it's
like look do you want to be associating
with a daughter of the enemy of the
people because that makes it look like
you're uh conspiring with them so they
had to put her on the street so there
was hand ringing in the Kremlin because
all these kids are understandably
killing themselves now because not only
the orphans like no one will talk to
them or associate with them so again no
matter how bad we all think it can get
there's more layers to Hell uh in this
you know evil place
and and what it shows as well is that
the understanding that people have in
the west of these issues they can't
possibly comprehend because in a way
Michael to give them their due unless
you've experienced it unless you've
heard the stories unless you've been
around people who've experienced that
it's impossible to to understand it just
is the life of constant fear so one of
my friends Henry who grew up in
Venezuela and is Venezuelan he came over
to the UK and he went for a meal with my
family my parents are now very old and
Henry was talking and my dad said to him
Henry you're going to need to speak
louder I can't hear you and he said I'm
sorry but in Venezuela we're used to
Whispering
yeah and you don't even notice you just
adapt constantly and as a result I don't
think that you can read about this but
unless you experience it it's impossible
to understand that's the tagline on the
back of the book it's almost impossible
to convey to a free people what it's
like to live in a totalitarian
dictatorship let me give you the closest
parallel even I could feel was when I
visited North Korea and the thing is if
you think about your environment right
you think about the wall behind you the
neon your clothes who you're talking to
the books in your room the microphones
when every aspect is different an alien
that some of that environment is
something completely impossible to
describe because like the difference for
a fish between being like in a river or
being in a fish tank it affects every
single aspect of everything you do and
that cult that kind of combination is so
much bigger than some of its parts and
again even having only spent one week in
North Korea
it's almost impossible for me to just
articulate what it's like to be in a
country where there's no internet and no
access to the outside world I can kind
of explain it it's like being in a dream
state where you're like kind of floating
in this country that's you know devoid
of attachment to anything outside itself
but to actually physically be there to
wake up and not know what day it is and
not have it really matter because you
don't have news every day is pretty much
the same as the other other than the
weekends we don't know what that's like
and here's the other thing that I think
for those of us you know the level of
Horrors they all knew they can't leave
so you know there's many of these
countries even war-torn countries right
you know the blitz you knew this is
going to end at some point right you
knew this is you know temp or even covid
this is not going to go on forever they
were told from birth this is your
reality and there's nowhere else to go
and don't even think about trying to get
out of here because if you do someone is
going to turn you in and your family
right and this is one of the things that
I think um when when people talk about
this in the west it's like the easiest
thing the easiest line to give people to
get them to understand what their
societies were like was those countries
had borders
to stop people getting out
I mean that tells you enough I think
about everything that was going on
inside we have borders we argue all the
Time in the West you know we've got to
enforce the borders because people want
to come in those countries had borders
to prevent people leaving
and also I talk extensively about the
Berlin Wall in this book because this
fell during my lifetime and I didn't
really appreciate why this was such a
big deal and what a kind of Monument to
obscenity the Berlin Wall was uh the
idea of encasing there's this great line
from a historian the book where I go
it's it's kind of deranged it's the only
prison on Earth where the people who are
imprisoned are the ones who are free
because the you know they encase West
Berlin entirely but they called it the
official term the East German term was
the anti-fascist rampart and it worked
great not one fascist even tried so much
as to get into East Berlin but it's not
just that you couldn't leave they would
also lie you know it's like you wouldn't
want to leave because on the far side of
the Iron Curtain you know it's it's uh
it's you know the clan runs everything
and people are homeless and they're
starving we have it so great here
there's this great scene
um in the late 80s when Bortz Elson who
was high up in the USSR at the time went
to Houston in to visit NASA
and as a side trip he stopped into a
supermarket the supermarket's still
there and he's walking around and this
isn't filled with dignitaries and
Senators these are like School teachers
and truck drivers and their the food
he's seeing he'd never seen his life and
he's flying back to uh the USSR via
Miami and on the plane he has his head
in his hands and he's like they had to
lie because otherwise people would
understand how bad we have it so again
it's not just that there's a narrative
or they're twisting the truth there's no
other way that like they knew how bad it
was and they lied constantly 24 7. and
frankly that cynicism toward the media
was one of the things that broke down
this totalitarian nightmare
so Michael that being the case does it
worry you the cynicism that we have
towards the media in our societies where
we no longer trust the media it's the
best thing ever these people are I mean
it's it's very healthy when you're
trying to construct a narrative based on
Lies when people don't believe what you
say and there's this amazing story like
the story of the Prague the um Velvet
Revolution in in Prague in in
Czechoslovakia is just just a beautiful
heartwarming story and and people can
look read about in the book but there
was the the police started beating
protesters men women and children just
they wouldn't let them leave they're
beating them near Winchester square and
rumor went out and it was reported on
like Voice of America and other outlets
that there was a student I'm blank in
his name was Christopher Smith was
killed by the cops and then the protests
got bigger and there were two students
by this name at the universities and the
authorities like he's fine and they were
and they brought out both of them from
the cameras they go look look
Christopher Smith is fine and they were
telling the truth but after decades no
one believed them they really thought
that they killed this kid and the
protests got bigger and bigger and
that's spoiler alert the entire
government resigned and it was a
peaceful transition that's why it's
called the revolution to a liberal
democracy which remains to this day so
there are many stories where the
cynicism towards those who lie and
oppress their own for a living uh was
the healthiest response
and Michael let's say that there's a
young kid watching this and by Kid I
mean somebody in their teens in college
and you know they're they're you know
they they believe in in communism and
all the rest of it what would you say to
this kid who may be listening and may be
open to being persuaded
um don't believe your teachers uh this
is where the poisoning starts the
universities and I would tell them to I
mean this is one of the reasons I wrote
this book you know it's to explain what
this was like what this really means in
practice and you know there's this
argument you guys are very familiar with
I'm sure that this wasn't real communism
real communism hasn't been tried it's
like Lennon and Trotsky were true
believers they were the kind of
evangelists they were the prophets that
all right we're going to not put
anything get anything in our way we're
not going to be weak we're not going to
be middling this is our chance to kind
of do full bore communism and and they
succeeded and what this book
demonstrates and history demonstrates is
what that actually means in practice and
again it's not you don't take my word
for it or or someone some conservative
it was Emma Goldman Alexander Berkman
who were hardcore hardcore violent
revolutionaries who saw it firsthand and
they were the ones who uh kind of warned
about it in the west to completely deaf
ears
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
a lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop Revival toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this offers legit and
will have you smelling like royalty the
good kind not prince Andrew get 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code trigger 20
at manscape.com it's time to throw out
all your old hygiene habits and upgrade
your life
and Michael that's one of the reasons
I'm excited about your book being out
because uh I see kind of in our space
whatever that space is we a lot of
people spend a lot of time focusing on
what's gone wrong you know you post
modern neo-marxism or whatever it is
people go okay this has happened this
has happened this is what's gone wrong
this is what's going bad this is what's
not working and like you said it does
lead a lot of people into a kind of
Dooms space in which they they feel that
you know America's over Britain's over
the West is tired you know we must
embrace our new Russian overlords or
whatever is the ending of that that
process and that has caused I think now
in in me and in lots of other people now
I feel a a search for a positive vision
of the future what people are starting
to think about okay we've we've
identified what the problems are with
wokeness we've identified what the
problems are with the two mainstream
parties and the establishment Etc the
media are clearly lying to us a lot of
the time Etc right and your book is a
okay I mean good yeah as we say in
Russians
everything is understood in comparison
so the comparison is useful now what
well I I I'm glad I can speak to you
guys about this specifically as opposed
to Americans because the British had
this before
1979. the the British Empire went from
the Sun never sets in the British Empire
because it spanned the globe to not
having electricity you had there like
four hours a day of electricity the
garbage in Leicester Square was two
meters tall uh it was a given that the
best days the Great Britain were behind
her and that the country is kind of a
historical joke at this point right it
was called the sick man of Europe yeah
right and someone who is very
controversial in in your country
um namely Margaret Thatcher said I can't
bear the idea of Britain in Decline now
she's a very controversial figure but
you can't dispute that Great Britain in
2023 is in a far better place than Great
Britain was in 1979 and the idea that
Great Britain is kind of a joke and over
I don't think is something people say
with any kind of credence anymore so
this is an example in your country in
not that long ago where people were
saying the same thing and with far more
reason there was there seemed to be no
mechanism to turn the ship around it's
got to be managed decline uh you know we
had our run Pitbull Chap and now it's
just kind of we're slowly drifting
toward the grave and that ship got
turned so that that's one example but
the other example is again why
do people ascribe the villains of the
day to be omnipotent and omniscient you
know one of the points that I make in
this book and that I constantly talk
about is the enemy class is not full of
impressive people these are Rishi
whatever his name is I don't pronounce
his last name Cirque these aren't Gods
you know these aren't these amazing
figures and you know I sure wouldn't
want to go up against them in an
argument like are you crazy these you
know so when you have this idea that you
know the people who are opposed to
Liberty and freedom and human dignity
are unstoppable when you look at who
these people are they're far closer to
to snakes than to gods and I'm not
saying at all that they wouldn't do the
worst atrocities possible that's part of
the point of the book but the point
being they don't always get their way
why are you allowing them to lie to you
and say we're always going to win
because that's all they do is lie at
some point I'm gonna get what I want or
at the the very least there's the
possibility and as long as there as
there is the possibility of Victory
people have to fight for it
yeah and one of the things that you are
highly critical or I would say things or
World Views is cynicism you hate a cynic
don't you Michael explain to me why I
think it's the worst I don't I don't say
worst okay but it's really one of the
most like kind of unconscionable
perspectives for people to have first of
all it's this kind of like too cool for
school everything sucks like it's true
ninety percent of movies suck ninety
percent of comedians suck ninety percent
of books suck possibly including my own
but you're telling me no books are good
no movies inspire you and change your
life no conversation makes you a better
person no program uh makes you think
about our world and our place in it so
when you're a cynic you preemptively
excuse yourself from achieving anything
or hoping for anything because it's just
like you hand wave it away and it's an
easy trap to fall into I think it is
very much uh perpetrated by the media
because it allows people to just kind of
you're cool if you're a cynic but if you
have hope or optimism or anything is
sunny that's juvenile or illegitimate or
kind of a joke and that's a very useful
technique to encourage people to stop
fighting for their values and decide up
hoping for things better for themselves
and their families and I think it's
regardless of someone's politics if
you're surrounded by this and I think
this is a very constant you can speak to
this also I'm sure it's a very Russian
perspective because I remember very
vividly you know there's this show
called Russian dolls which was the
Russian version of um oh man it was so
good I remember the whole family sitting
down to watch it I talk about it all the
time because it was the first time you
could see Russian politicians being
satirized and made fun of and uh that
and it's never happened before or since
really properly wait there might be a
different show then here in the states
it's our version of Jersey Shore with
with a bunch of Russians
I was thinking about a different one in
the 90s we had this show called uh
cooling puppets it was a recording the
splitting image anyway sorry but the
point I brought it up is there was this
scene where this girl she'd been
struggling she she had like eight
different Majors she didn't know what to
do she took an aptitude test and it said
lawyer and she's like oh you know what I
enjoyed my pre-law class so she's
there's a scene she's out there Mom
they're getting manicures or whatever
she goes mom you know I finally figured
out I want to be a lawyer first reaction
how are you going to pay for it and she
has this complete breakdown it's just
like why is it whenever I have something
positive in my life your first reaction
is to look for a flaw to look for a
problem what people don't know how to
pay for law school this isn't on and she
just loses it and I could really relate
to that because this kind of like always
looking for the darkness always looking
for the way out to give up is so
pernicious where as opposed to me and
and the point of the book and just I
think people should fight in general is
there's the possibility that you're
going to achieve your dreams and I gotta
tell you I failed a lot in my life and
I'm fine with it and I'm sure you guys
have too because as long as I gave it a
good college try I don't always get what
I want I feel happy and I can meet my
maker knowing I did my best with what I
had yeah well this is such a such an
important point and I think one of the
reasons that
these cynical narratives are so
pernicious and so common is I don't know
have you ever heard of this experiment
where like they put a rat in a cage with
an electrified floor and as long and it
gives us the right an electric shock
with a certain regularity and what they
found was as if you put a button in the
cage that the rat can turn off the
electric shock the rat will carry on you
know trying to stop the electric shocks
but if there is no button and they can't
control its environment then the rat
just lies down and takes it basically
and I think a lot of these responses
that people are attempted to go into
they're a feeling of a lack of control
yeah they're a feeling like there is
these and and you both left and right
have a version of it you know to the
left it's systemic whatever it's
structures of Oppression it's the
patriarchy it's whatever and to the sort
of more anti-work ride there's Davos and
Klaus Schwab is personally you know
taking over their life or whatever it is
and and it's it's a way of basically
saying I don't control anything I can
have no impact I'm just going to sit
here and be resigned and cynical yeah I
I was on some conservative podcast they
were talking about how Joe Biden is
putting the last nail in the coffin in
America I'm like we're One Nail away
from America being destroyed what does
that even mean destroyed right and it's
just and if you your perspective is that
the Biden Administration in two years
and 51 Democratic senators can destroy
America well it's a wrap and get out of
this country because you hate America
because to me it's just absurd that you
know a country as prosperous as we are
which certainly has problems let's let
me not put sweep it on the rug but to
say that we're two years away from
absolute our destruction to me is
absolutely crazy to the point of being
dishonest
it's also these narratives are highly
addictive the
and we're not going to mention any names
certain channels that Feed and Fuel a
doomsday narrative they get millions of
views
look how [__] things can get and it's
coming to America right now yeah exactly
get your copy but they put out the same
narrative again and again there doesn't
seem to be very little Variety in the
output you look at it and even a cursory
glance will make it or once you analyze
it you realize that a lot of these
arguments don't have a lot of Merit yet
people tune in they love it don't they
oh and then you could have and the thing
is then they can say that they're being
rational because they could open up any
newspaper and find bad news and be like
look look I'm not being irrational this
the newspaper validates my perspective
so it does become a self-fulfilling
cycle
um I think kovid certainly allowed
people who are you know neurotic or
anxious or depressed now to externalize
their Neurosis because now it's not
calling from inside the house it's the
whole country or the whole world that's
experiencing this and how can you expect
me to have any hope or vision of
Happiness so I I think it's a very
useful technique if you want to conquer
a people or a peoples to convince them
that their victory over you is
impossible and then you don't have to
fight because they could just go home
shrug their shoulders and be like all
right you know I can't win I have no
hope the people I'm against are too
powerful or have been around too long or
control too many institutions and I'm
just gonna kind of you know watch
sitcoms have a pint and uh that's the
end of that and I I think it's it's a
very smart move on their part but I
really hope that the people listening to
this don't fall into that trap and you
don't have to be this you know
Braveheart Freedom Fighter but you can
certainly be a better person tomorrow
than you are today we all have that
power within us you know not everyone is
going to be Joe Rogan but we could still
be successful podcasters as an example
uh so when people put in that
perspective you have that kind kind of
motivation to you know do something
about the values that you hold and also
not all of those actions have to be
public actions I think you know when you
you not everyone's Joe Rogan and you can
be a successful podcaster but you could
also just have kids and raise them well
or you could make a difference in the
job that you do whatever that job is and
and that in it in itself will not only
make the world but it actually is going
to make your life a hell of a lot better
versus sitting there and listening to
yet another three-hour conversation
about how civil war is coming you know
what I mean and it's also here's the
other thing with cynicism it's very
important for cynics to make sure
everyone around them is cynical it's
almost like a zombie apocalypse because
as soon as you have one example that
disproves your narrative that everything
sucks and we're doomed your entire
hypothesis falls apart so
psychologically it is necessary for them
when they are surrounded by people who
are
if not thriving at least going in that
direction to pull the rug out from under
them because otherwise they're going to
have to do some dark looking in the
mirror and they're not going to like
what they find so I very much caution
people if you're surrounded by this kind
of negativity in your life especially in
casual friends make sure that this
person is more of a benefit than it cost
to you because it really is very
pernicious and sinister
Michael do you think part of the problem
as well is that people just buy into
systems and paradigms way too much so
whatever the system may be like the
college system they believe that you go
to college you get your college degree
and that your life when you leave will
be sorted and well life doesn't work
like that dive doesn't happen like that
just because you get a college degree
doesn't mean you're going to get a great
job whatever school you go to do you
think that's part of the problem as well
yes and I think it's by Design and I
think it starts in school because the
whole point of school is to make people
as homogeneous as possible to break
young Spirits you don't want little boys
running around you want them asking too
many questions you want to everyone's
learning at the same rate as everybody
else everyone is told that we all kind
of basically think the same these are
things that are completely untrue and it
there's this winnowing effect where if
you're kind of challenging The Narrative
that the teacher at the front of the
room was on more often than not
apologies to your audience uh if they
get offended at this a mediocre person
uh you are really kind of taught a very
bad lesson very early on and I think
this is intentional because I think
schools I I I'm pretty sure it's even
worse in the UK than the United States
are there to design to teach kids not to
think critically and not to challenge
basic assumptions you can only challenge
within a context that is presented as
you you know the equivalent of setting
kids up for the Overton window uh and I
think it's very hard at a young age to
kind of break out of that and not kind
of be under that thumb uh but it's
something I think that's very very
necessary and that I personally have to
do myself as well
Michael moving on well hold on a second
are you not going to tell him you're a
former team yeah yeah
he slags off teachers you say nothing
stands up for yourself
I'll back you up come on no I do agree I
actually agree with you Michael so in
the UK what uh education has in fact
become it's not it I would even say it's
worse than that because education has
actually become uh every school is now a
factory for data harvesting yes it's not
about teaching it's about Factory it's a
factory for data harvesting so that when
the education minister of the day is
questioned by his uh his one of his
opponents they can then go well look the
you know the grammar you know the kids
are writing better by 22 are they
actually writing better no not really
you're just teaching them to pass the
test which has little to no value and
it's just basically justifying your job
that's also the problem of education is
that it's now a political football as
well I would just like to say on behalf
of everyone here at trigonometry we
believe there's some very good teachers
out there and have tremendous respect
for them and by no means are we
suggesting that you're all terrible I
didn't say all
you just meant marks it's not a game of
Russian Roulette I'd want to play
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
you're not a big fan of school Michael I
gather no not government schools
especially I don't know how they are in
the UK but here in the United States
this it's probably the only place that
many people experience violence in their
lifetimes uh and this is kind of this
idea that you know first of all everyone
learning at the same rate as everyone
else is nonsensical uh they the point of
schooling explicitly is to make good
citizens and what that means is people
who are so vile and obedient that's the
ex I mean it's a euphemism for a very
pernicious goal and to have everyone
basically thinking the same things
within narrow parameters and and that's
how you get a you know powerful state
Michael here's the thing it's not also
that it's also to give you certain
skills for you to be able to access
education the workforce but I take your
point do you sometimes not worry though
Michael and I have this myself in that
your experiences has led you with this
to such to have such a deep distrust of
authority that you worry you can go too
far the other way
no I'm an anarchist there's no too far
I'm there I've told turn the dial up to
11.
so you just think to yourself like
because surely some we do need some form
of government Michael surely we do in
order to make the right in order to make
sure that you know the road trains don't
say the trains it's about where they run
yeah exactly well you know you know the
roads work you know
the Water Works whatever else do you not
think that we need government for that
without government how do we have water
I think my God no I don't think we need
government for any of that and I think
without government who's going to
imprison us in our homes for weeks at a
time for no reason my God it's it's
unconscionable no I don't think I think
first of all I don't like that term we
need because that always means I want
um and no I do not want government at
all I there are of course uh
organizations and mechanisms that are
important that establish rules and
regulations within their purview but in
the sense of a government now I think
government's illegitimate
so how how would Society work without
government let's say Society works this
is a kind of a sidebar but Society Works
despite government uh everything that
works in society is done voluntarily by
people at Adam Smith talked about this
at Great length by people fighting for
their values working peace leave with
everyone else it's only when force is
introduced into a relationship via
private criminals such as muggers or
public criminals which are governments
that you have strife and uh um other
things like that well I mean if you
remember we talked about anarchism a lot
in our last conversation so people can
go and go and check out the full
conversation if they want
um
Michael so
you I mean one of the things we talked
about is the need for Hope and the need
for uh the belief that positive positive
things are possible and I appreciate
that in your conception positive change
would be to get rid of government well
can I say one thing it's not just
positive things are possible this whole
book is demonstrating that positive
things have happened so this isn't some
Pollyanna thing about like oh hope for
the best we've seen great extremely
positive things happen within our
lifetime but they're not discussed
because as you guys mentioned they don't
fit this doomsday narrative well right
and actually I mean you made the point
right at the beginning about the Cold
War and maybe this is a good opportunity
to come back to because I think to
answer your question I think part of the
reason is it's kind of like covert in a
way once something is bad is over people
just want to move on right I think
that's part of it another part of it is
that the entity which previously was our
enemy in the west the Soviet Union no
longer exists and so it was very easy to
go okay well that's done now let's not
worry too much but as we see in terms of
what's happening in Ukraine now you know
things don't it's not like that part of
the world suddenly just disappeared or
all became liberal beautiful liberal
democracies or whatever and that Legacy
I mean that's what's happening Ukraine
now is continuing to run isn't it oh
absolutely so you know one of the points
I make is that if someone is you know
anarchists get accused of being utopians
Utopias don't exist but progress does
things great victories happen on a
national uh International and personal
level all the time and uh if we want if
we're going to be cynics we're going to
pretend that's not true and it's just
demonstrably false like everyone
listening to this has had great
victories in their lives moments where
things had been where your fears you
know there's this kind of imagine going
back in time 10 years ago and talking
yourself and remembering all those fears
you had all those anxieties many of them
never ended up happening and some of
them did and you know what you were able
to handle them you were strong enough so
I think that kind of is very important
to uh have in mind to realize that and
but the other thing is I I think we
underestimate how much the media and the
Academia love war love Bloodshed because
the Cold War and the fall of the Soviet
Union was very largely a peaceful one
you don't have this triumphalism that we
storm Normandy and all these boys lost
their lives and of course I'm not you
know kind of dismissing what their
accomplishments was and those enormous
sacrifices to be fair but that story is
much more kind of easy to tell in terms
of heroism than a bunch of people got
together looked around and said this is
not right and we're going to do
something about and we're going to
dismantle sometimes against our own will
this enormous edifice that has been
built up over the decades
um what about Rocky four
[Laughter]
so so
Jay so so so you know that was one of
the reasons I wrote this is because that
Narrative of the victory of good over
evil is not something in popular
Consciousness but I think it needs to be
especially as as you said uh Russia and
Ukraine are still very much in the news
today for obvious reasons and do you
think part of it as well Michael is
nowadays I almost feel like because of
this slightly you know we do see the
world through this sort of
post-modernist everything is relative
lens to some extent like you say good
and evil most people couldn't even
Define what good and evil are anymore
right I don't know about any more I
think this has been a long time where
this idea of Good and Evil was speaking
to earlier is regard as simplistic or
naive or juvenile or 1950s it's and this
was you know the leading up to the last
or the book The idea was they taunt
because the argument was okay look we
tried to fight communism in North Korea
that was in the Korean War that was a
draw we tried to kind of uh Cuba the
Cuban Missile Crisis the Vietnam Amore
was a disaster for the West the rational
sane informed person knows the Soviet
Union isn't going anywhere we have to
make our peace with it this is going to
be a two polar world for Millennia Star
Trek at Chekhov because even in the
far-flung future it's going to be the
Americans and the Russians and Ronald
Reagan who became president in elected
1980 sat down in the late 70s and he
said to his colleague he goes do you
want to hear my strategy for the Cold
War it's simple and some might say
simplistic we win they lose
and you know for him and Margaret
Thatcher with the home office when she
was excuse me the foreign office when
she was dealing with Gorbachev they told
her these changes are cosmetic they're
not going anywhere you don't know what
you're talking about you have to be
realistic and realism means you have to
accept that this is going to be two
superpowers in perpetuity and my
favorite moment well not my favorite up
there is
when like valessa who was the head of
Poland was talking to helmet Cole who's
the head of West Germany and LEC
ballester goes you know I don't think
the Berlin Wall is going to be around
for much longer I mean the way things
are changing so so quickly and Hell
Nicole laughs in his face and he goes
you're young you don't understand how
these things work this is going to be a
long process it fell the next day
and helmick call says I'm at the wrong
party and got on a plane and got his ass
out of Warsaw so there's so many moments
in this book when educated smart and
cynical people are like you can't expect
things to get better or if they are
going to get better it's just kind of
putting a bandage on a greater wound
this disease is going to be Eternal
we've tried everything we had and
nothing's going to change and things
happened gradually and then suddenly
that's so interesting because as you
were speaking that I was thinking kind
of looking 10 15 years into the future
and uh I don't think you know five to
ten years ago or 15 years ago anyone in
the west would have really given half a
[__] about the leader of Russia Dying
For example okay well they've got a new
one called Boris again great you know
who cares right
but now
that would be like a very significant
moment right and that is going to happen
in the next 10 15 years almost certainly
or at least there will be a change of
leadership for sure so we're kind of
going to a world in which things really
are starting to matter again in in a in
a very bad way but also in in a very
significant way
well yeah I mean I'm gonna push back a
little towards the the late 70s early
80s you know Reagan kept trying to have
um Summits with the Soviet Union but the
leaders kept dying on him because there
was one old man after another you know
uh and he didn't really know what to do
about it and then when Gorbachev comes
in he was the first Soviet leader to be
born after the creation uh 1917 of the
of what became the USSR and this was a
radical change in a direction that
everyone listened to this I believe
would very much be in favor of so it
certainly is the case that leadership
does matter and you know when Putin goes
away the next leader could be worse most
certainly or it could be someone who's
you know better or who knows even what
those terms mean in this context
um but yeah it it it's interesting how
forgotten uh this whole story was and
and I think that's just completely uncon
and it's just what what really bothers
me isn't just necessarily the Cold War
because that's kind of high politics
what's being forgotten is the oppression
that these people went through the the
secret police the show people were put
on trial and forced to denounce their
own families and admit to things that
were literally impossible oh I met
Trotsky at this hotel even though the
whole even the hotel no longer had
existed and then you had the reporters
you know defending these trials there
were so many signatories to these
letters in the west saying we need to
adopt the ways of Stalin and they have
free speech there and you don't know
what you're talking about because you're
trapped by the bourgeoisie so there's
just so many receipts of of just uh not
to mention the gulags of course of
atrocities that so many people whose
names we will never know have been
forgotten and I'm like you know Over My
Dead Body is this going to be swept
under the rug of History Michael does it
does the experiences of your family and
the experiences of writing this book
does it make you hyper Vigilant within
your own country as to your own freedoms
being eroded
I don't know but it makes me Hyper
Village Vigilant about the nature of
evil because Americans have this idea
that evil is someone with weird facial
hair banging the desk and filming at the
mouth and what happens in these
countries and I'm sure you guys can
speak to this as well is it's these
little bureaucrats these absolute
mediocre people just just the bottom of
the barrel who are put in positions of
power simply because they're following
the party line and they will do
everything to maintain that power and
Lord it over you like you know just it's
it's the it's the person when you want
to go to the hospital and get medicine
and he's the one guy standing between
you and getting medication for your
family and he's going to make you tap
dance because this is his opportunity to
feel like a big shot the best example of
this was ciao chesku you know who's the
head of Romania and in any other country
you know if you take one look at this
guy the complete simpleton he'd be some
kind of mail clerk who would be
befuddled when the address says you know
73 Smith Avenue but it's 73 Smith Street
and he wouldn't know what to do about it
and just be kind of crapping his pants
but this guy was given absolute power
and was praised you know from sunrise to
sunset in this country and what happened
to the chachescos in Romania is you know
one of my favorite stories in this book
well right uh they I I this is one of my
favorite stories as well because it kind
of shows you the thing that you're
talking about which is things change
quickly and they change suddenly because
uh he formally at least had a 90
something percent approval rating the
day he was summarily executed the day
before he was summarily executed after
being arrested so uh well on that
positive note Michael uh uh to things
can change quickly and suddenly and for
the better
um it's been a pleasure speaking with
you I hope everybody gets to to read the
white pill which is a great read and uh
before we let you go and before we do
our questions for our local supporters
as they've already submitted uh tell us
what is the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that you think we
really should be uh the perniciousness
of the universities and those who staff
them I think that is where the poisoning
starts uh and I'm very gladdened by in
America at least it went from people uh
thinking the fights in Washington and
the government and then they've shifted
to the tactics of the corporate press
but behind them is the last leg of that
stool and that is the University system
and I'm very very gladdened by this
because I think a University staff
professors of the Intel Intelligentsia
are as a rule not particularly
impressive people uh and and just nasty
and and just very small-minded and when
we take the fight to them I think that's
when Victory will be achieved and I
don't think they're going to be able to
put up much of a fight at all because
they've never had to defend themselves
Michael thank you so much for coming on
the show if people want to get your book
if people want to find your other works
online where is the best place to do
that uh white pillbook.com and I'm on
Twitter at Michael malice and I
apologize in advance for the crap of my
social media output and
malice.locals.com
uh awesome Michael thanks for coming on
uh guys head on over to locals where
we're going to ask your questions and
you'll get to see the answers and only
you'll get to see the answers if you
support the show thanks for watching
thanks for listening and we see you very
soon another brilliant episode like this
one or raw show all of them go out at
7pm UK time and for those of you your
trigonometry on the go it's always
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
my version of national divorce is uh
Texas regains its sovereignty from the
occupying regime in DC and everyone else
can [__] off and do whatever they want
[Music]